there's no irregular cheese there's
something in it
hi my name is olya and I'm a chef de
cuisine I've been in this industry for
about 15 years now
hi my name is Diana and I have been
cooking for eight years I am a sous chef
and my favorite thing to cook and eat is
pasta comes in a box that was my
childhood I like to make my cheese sauce
one of my favorite ready to make
macaroni and cheese is Kraft a little
bit of a higher budget for my mac and
cheese so I go for that white cheddar oh
I like the pouch
[Music]
alright I didn't know we're gonna be
blindfolded yeah I guess I think I want
to smell it first useful all right am I
going first yeah
Wow I know this this scent it's familiar
a little powdery all right very cheesy
mm-hmm the noodles are small small
enough to fit in a box someone today
mushy the noodles are a little mushy and
the cheese is a bit grainy I would say
even like artificial the cheese is uh I
wish I could see the color is it like
super orange Pepsodent
my mind the cheese wasn't like grated
that's for sure but it's comforting it
tastes like childhood not as smooth as I
would like my macaroni and cheese to be
a boss mallet yeah I do know it smell a
little bit of garlic all right you hear
that cheese I did
I was Pinette the positive oh let's
watch do you think different quality mac
and cheese is sound this one sounded
more saucy I heard the cheese when I
lifted the noodle it's a penny noodle I
would think this one is probably a
little bit more expensive than the
previous one yeah and I just melt garlic
mm-hmm our thirteenth flower
okay it tastes like it was like a cheese
sauce that was made I chased a lot of
the flower and it's not that cheesy it's
like more like garlicky and buttery
yeah it's less mushy this noodle is
better than the previous noodle a
higher-quality knodel okay got it
nice smell not much stuff oh my gosh
what I smell it
I smell I'm over I smell like a smoky
I'm hoping it has some bacon in it
something that there's no like regular
cheese there's something in it bacon
EJ said yeah Wilhelmy sorry hmm yeah
definitely the noodle is why is this a
name of this no no that's the one that's
like it's a different note oh it's a
spiral what yeah it's not all bow but it
has bacon in it so that's good and the
sauce is not greeny there's garlic
mm-hmm it's more clean neat they
definitely took their time making this
one and then I was like crunchy things
so I'm guessing it's like baked
there's something in there as well they
put garlic in it I can taste garlic
along with the bacon and there's
something on it is there like
breadcrumbs mixed in it texturally is a
lot different than the other two and the
bacon helps for sure I think that the
first one we had was the cheapest one
yes I'm willing to bet it was Kraft for
sure the third one was the best one yeah
I would say that's probably the most
expensive one I want to say the one
right here is definitely the cheapest I
don't know where you're pointing I'm not
asking to the camera to one right here
the Kraft one is definitely the cheapest
one on this side but between these two I
feel like maybe this one's more
expensive so I might be this
I don't know what you're doing I'm not
talking to you I think don't let the
bacon might be the second cheapest and
then I know but the one in the middle
might be the most it was like trying too
hard
she thinks you're trying to trick her
yeah I'm gonna go with this is the
cheapest one over here and then the
middle one is the second no I'm gonna
agree and then the last one by me is the
most expensive one it is orange oh gee
yeah that's the stuff though right yay
you're more right you stuck to your guns
I doubt it
man if I was wrong I was gonna quit my
job what is this that's really good $100
what are they they're like 50 up 50
under the plate down
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]